the central thesis of Joe Biden's  presidency articulated in the earliest  days of his campaign and reiterated just  last week is that we are now engaged in  a battle for the soul of our nation I  don't know if you've looked at some of  his appointees recently  I think the thesis is correct  Joe Biden's assistant Health secretary  is a man who thinks that he is a woman  and who demands that we cast straight  little kids Joe Biden's Deputy assistant  Energy Secretary is a psychosexual  sadist who dresses grown men up in  leather dog outfits and photographs  himself dragging them around on a leash  and Joe Biden's new Deputy monkey pox  coordinator is a store brand Anton LaVey  whose headshot depicts him wearing a  leather pentagram chest harness on top  of his other pentagram pectoral tattoo  now in Joe Biden's defense  he never told us which side of the  battle he is on  so we may be in a battle for the soul of  a Nation but if Personnel is policy  our soul is in trouble